welcome
to our deep dive on google cloud's
managed microsoft active directory and
applications
my name is siddharth bhai i'm a product
manager lead
for our managed security services that
span
identity and access management and
certificates
my twitter handle is my first name last
name
i've enjoyed speaking at industry
conferences starting with the directory
experts conference
back in 2008 in chicago
and i'm so glad i've had the good
fortune of speaking with
and meeting so many of you at google
cloud next
san francisco then tokyo and today
digitally
in this new virtual reality let's jump
in
what we'll be covering today is an
introduction as to why do you need
active directory in the cloud
i'll give you a demo of our managed
microsoft ad service
we'll talk about some interesting
capabilities
work on infrastructure design and round
it off with security
so let's jump in
in some ways this talk has been in the
making for a couple of years
we first came and spoke to you about
running self-managed active directory on
google cloud
in next 2019 we introduced the managed
service
for microsoft active directory and today
we'll dive deep
to make sure we're all on the same page
in the first few slides i'll do a quick
recap
and then we'll jump into all new content
so what are the identity and access
management challenges facing us today
idm security leaders are still having to
work through
a large number of legacy systems that
are mission critical to the business
a lot of the times active directory
tends to be the backbone of these
enterprise great solutions
sharepoint sql server myriad kerberos
and ldap apps are just a few examples
active directory takes time and
expertise to manage well
and one of the things i notice while
working with customers
is a lot of the times the documentation
that exists for certain applications
is tailored for on-premises use cases
and is tricky to try and use directly on
the cloud
to give you an example let me show you a
visual from a recent solutions guide
around modernizing.net applications
you can see it talks about three phases
rehost
re-platform and re-architect and rebuild
as you can notice active directory and
identity are pervasive across the
spectrum
but to go through this journey your
active directory needs to evolve as well
a lot of the existing third-party
documentation
will not work for these modern use cases
so what's the way out
last year we introduced to you our
managed service for microsoft active
directory
the service is a highly available
hardened google cloud service
running actual microsoft ad the service
is in general availability
this enables you to manage
authentication and authorization
for your ad dependent applications and
workloads
it automates ad server maintenance and
security configuration
the service is multi-regional something
i'll talk more about
later in the session and it can connect
with your on-premises
active directory domains because it runs
the actual microsoft active directory
domain controllers
this really helps you with your
application compat challenges
first we run the service using the
latest windows server bills on the
long-term servicing channel
with the service you can use ed's
built-in features such as
group policy and single sign-on
you can also use your standard active
directory tools such as
remote server administration toolkit to
manage your microsoft active directory
domains
it's virtually maintenance free for you
because you provide it as a managed
service
that is a highly available topology with
domain controllers deployed in separate
zones
i'm excited to share the service comes
with a enterprise grade sla
the service automatically patches active
directory servers
takes ad snapshots for recovery monitors
for issues
and replaces domain controllers that
might run into any issues
the service hardens active directory by
implementing secure
defaults and appropriate network
firewall rules
behind the scenes what's happening is
each managed active directory tenant
comes up on its own isolated network in
an isolated project
it aligns to active directory's tiered
administration model
the service provides for you a delegated
administrator account out of the back
and you're welcome to come and create
additional accounts for your needs
it can work alongside your existing
active directory
using active directory trusts and the
service supports both one-way
and two-way truss so this was a quick
overview of what the service is about
now let's jump in and take a look at the
service and its capabilities
let me now go into a demo where i'll
show you the experience of working with
the service using our google cloud
console
we start this demo inside the google
cloud console
if you were to navigate through to
security
and then down to manage microsoft ad
that would bring you to this page
as you can see we have asked google
cloud to create and manage
two active directory domains here
corporate.example.com
and partners.example.com let's take a
closer look at the first one
we're now looking at the domain details
page of the first domain
as you can see corporate.example.com has
domain controllers deployed
in the u.s westbound region and the
domain controllers are fine the domain
is healthy
the security model of manage microsoft
ad
is that the active directory domain is
made available and accessible only
from the networks which you choose to
authorize
in this case we have asked for the
domain to be made available
on this specific network one of the
interesting things
worth calling out is google cloud's vpcs
are multi-region capable
what this means is though we have domain
controllers from this domain deployed in
us west one
as long as this vpc has subnets from the
other regions
you can already bring up your active
directory based infrastructure
in any of those other regions as well
another interesting thing worth talking
about is a lot of the times you already
have active directory running elsewhere
and so we support trust relationships
from managed microsoft
active directory domains as i scroll
down you can see in this case
i already have a one-way trust set up
with
an on-premises active directory domain
know that manage
active directory suppose multiple trust
relationships with one or more forests
active directory forest running
elsewhere and
you can set up either a one-way or a
two-way
trust relationship based on your
security posture needs as well as
the needs of the infrastructure that
you're trying to run on google cloud
now let's take a look at the other
managed microsoft active directory
domain
this is partners.example.com and one of
the interesting things which you'll
probably notice right away
is it has domain controllers deployed in
two separate regions
so it's the exact same active directory
domain with domain controllers deployed
in these two regions
one of the interesting things is as your
infrastructure needs evolve you can come
back to the service
and ask for domain controllers to be
deployed in additional regions
or to be removed from a specific region
if that is what you desire
so in the demo you saw me talk about are
multi-region capable
vpcs that's an interesting thing about
them
is that with google cloud you can bring
up your infrastructure
in different physical locations and they
can still be on the same
vpc network without requiring any vpns
i checked recently our google cloud
inter-region latency and throughput
dashboard
and i found that the highest latency
between any one us region to any other
us region
was still under 70 milliseconds
so the same managed active directory
domain can serve
all four regions so you deploy manage ad
domain in one region
add that vpc as an authorized network
and your infrastructure in any of those
other regions can utilize it
however you can do something even more
interesting with manage microsoft ad
our multi-regional managed microsoft ed
service compounds the power
of multi-regional google cloud vpcs
your apps running in different regions
can have domain controllers be deployed
closer to them and this does a couple of
things one
it simplifies your active directory
based deployment because it's the same
ad domain
therefore the same active directory
domain prefix
and the same similar copies synchronized
copies of the active directory database
second it makes your active directory
deployment more resilient to regional
outages
this is something that's uniquely
differentiating for us compared to other
managed ed services you might come
across
when it comes to pricing it's a pretty
straightforward model
when you think about managing microsoft
active directory domain there is of
course a cost of the infrastructure
itself
there is also the cost of taking
snapshots and backups
being able to restore the active
directory domain in the event of any
outages or disasters
and other things that go into your tco
all of these are bundled up for you
and made available in a single base
price
of 40 cents per hour per manage 80
domain
if you want to run microsoft managed
active directory
you do not need to procure additional
licenses
for the domain controllers themselves
for any ad-based infrastructure that you
might choose to utilize
or work with managed microsoft ad you
would have separate pricing
and separate licensing considerations as
usual
the multi-regional aspects is also
interesting to build into the pricing
model
so that same base price you multiply
that by the number of regions where you
want your manage any domain to be
deployed
in this example i take the 40 cents per
hour multiplied by 2
and that's how you'd be priced for the
manage 80 domain in this case
now this has been a memorable year in
more ways than one
geopolitics pandemics regulations
whichever way you look it's been a
little rough
so you need to be prepared for an
environment where being able to say the
infrastructure can match
shifting business priorities is
important and our manage microsoft ed
service
is ready for this new era let me show
you how
i'm now showing you a visual that shows
you some gcloud commands
first you'll notice that this managed ed
domain has domain controllers deployed
in us west one
i go ahead and i add a region australia
southeast asia 1
then after that operation completes you
will notice the same managead domain has
domain controllers deployed in both of
these regions
now i can go ahead and remove the first
region
via this gcloud command so what's
happening behind the scenes is these new
domain controllers have been deployed in
the new regions
and then we have removed the old domain
controllers from the previous region
it's highly available in each region and
behind the scenes the service is taking
care of
important ad operations such as fismo
roll transfers and others
so just for fun i looked up the distance
between oregon usa
and sydney australia google maps says
that's over seven thousand seven hundred
miles
you still find cloud use cases but it's
a mess to try and move
a single vm here we just moved
the entire active directory domain
no vpns no active directory migration
no need to tinker with set history
and no reconfiguration of any
applications
you are now able to claim that no active
directory data resides in your old
region
and you're able to satisfy your
auditor's needs by showing them
all of these regional movements clearly
be there in
cloud audit logging the domain remains
available
the apps keep working active directory
keeps responding to dc locator calls
through this transition
so that's an interesting application of
the multi-regional
microsoft active directory managed
domain
now that we have spent a few minutes
understanding the service i wanted to
dig a little deeper
and start giving you a sense of how can
you design your infrastructure
and best practices like with so many
enterprise deployments
it starts with networking considerations
you want to make sure that if you're
running this manage microsoft ad domain
and 80 dependent infrastructure with
your other infrastructure
you think about hybrid networking cloud
vpn
and interconnect are a couple of
interesting choices for you to think
through dns resolution that is being
able to resolve the name of the active
directory domain
is an important consideration in adbas
environments
and so for this you want to think about
how will that work
when you have your infrastructure
running even off google cloud
and running on google cloud in different
places
you want to think about possibly
resolving dns in both directions
cross project connectivity is another
important consideration
if you have ad based infrastructure in
mind i'd recommend
taking a look at shared vpcs if you
decide to utilize shared vpcs ask for
the manage microsoft ed domain
to be created from the host project if
for other reasons a hub
spoke model is interesting for you you
may want to think about
how will you have network connectivity
from the infrastructure that is running
in spokes
and look at alternative solutions such
as vpns for those cases
manage microsoft active directory
seamlessly integrates with cloud dns
so as a result of that vms that you
create on authorized networks
are able to come up and discover managed
microsoft ad domains without requiring
any client-side network configuration
how does this work so if you look at the
box on the top left you'll notice that
managed microsoft ad creates a private
dns zone
in the tenant project that is hosting
your managed ad domain controllers
then manage microsoft ad creates dns
peering between the authorized network
and the vpc host ad domain and dns
so using the box that you see on the top
right you are now able to
forward all the requests for the ad
domains namespace
to private dns zone in the tenant
project
if you're thinking of running your
infrastructure in a hybrid configuration
and want to be able to resolve dns
ad-based dns queries from your other
infrastructure
that is also possible to do this you
would look to create an
inbound dns policy now let's shift gears
and talk about identities
there is three typical ways people look
to deploy ad-based
infrastructure on google cloud one is
you can have
this be a standalone active directory
forest
fully managed in cloud you can either
create active directory optics or
migrate them
in using other tools the second topology
is a resource ad forest model in this
case your managed microsoft ed domain
houses your cloud vm computer and
service accounts
your on-premises ad domain continues to
host the user objects
and you can connect the two using a
one-way or a two-way ad trust
the third model is a mixed account
resource forest model
in this case your users who have only
cloud
only needs can be fully serviced and
managed in cloud
your cloud infrastructure need not bleed
back into your on-premises ed
infrastructure which is typically
washed more closely and deemed more
sensitive and this type of
topology is also very popular as a part
of a broader cloud migration strategy
when you think about identities let's
put it in perspective
with separate dev and production
environments which a lot of people
run when it comes to running
infrastructure in the cloud
what you could do for this is you could
choose to get two separate managed
microsoft ed domains
and still have a trust going back to the
same on-premises
user active directory domain so this way
you can still get single sign-on with
those same
on-premises ad accounts and you can more
easily
experiment and test while preventing
proliferation of forgotten active
directory accounts in your manage ad
instances
now let's shift the focus to running
independent applications
to do this you obviously want to think
about where and how your infrastructure
will run within the google cloud
resource hierarchy if you choose to
utilize
the org policy just know that you should
set your resource location constraint to
allow global
so that your ad dependent infrastructure
can work with managed microsoft ad
as you've been seeing we have designed
flexibility into the service where you
can always come back and add and remove
regions or add and remove authorized
networks
so you can get started with what you
need today and the service will evolve
with you when you're ready to
upgrade or enhance your infrastructure
i also encourage you to leverage our
networking and compute solutions
to be able to more effectively run your
ad dependent apps
migrate for compute engine is definitely
a powerful offering for you to think
about
our managed instance groups also tend to
be really popular particularly with
their auto scaling capabilities
i wanted to quickly talk about a
solution which allows you
to have your new vms come up and be
automatically domain joined
and be able to work with manage
microsoft active directory
so i have a link on the slide below in
case you'd like to go check it out
but as many of you likely know an
effective domain join story then makes
it possible
and easy for the infrastructure to opt
into the ad based ecosystem for
authentication and authorization
let's now come to probably the most
important topic of all which is enhanced
security the first thing i'd like to
cover is when it comes to running
your active directory infrastructure for
you we take that very seriously and have
built in
several safeguards to help make that be
effective
first the managed ad domain controllers
all have
private ip addresses and run in isolated
tenants
they do not have direct public internet
access
second shielded vms are standard for all
managed ad domain controllers
we test os patches before applying them
and through the patch
process your active directory domain
remains available
for any active directory related service
accounts that the
service utilizes in ad the credentials
are rotated using industry standard
techniques
the service credentials for managed are
never shared between different instances
we have procedures in place to have
restricted production access
even for google cloud engineers human
access
is for advanced double shooting only and
is restricted to those who are on call
all access is logged and audited
internally
and access requires validated
justification another aspect of security
comes to
how do the ad identities translate to
identity and access management
to show that let me walk you through
this visual
you can see on the bottom right i have
this managed ad instance
and i've gone ahead and created user
accounts and groups
in this manage ad instance you can now
choose to run
a google cloud directory sync tool on a
vm in compute engine
and thereby sync your active directory
users
and passwords from here to your cloud
identity domain
you can go ahead and configure the cloud
identity domain
to point to an external identity
provider in this case
i have it configured to point to adfs
which
in turn can go ahead and authenticate
the users that are housed inside
managed active directory you are now all
set to utilize these
managed ad hosted identities in your
identity and access management policies
in google cloud to show that
i will go ahead and walk you through
this demo where you will notice
how i'm able to utilize these managed ad
hosted users
to enhance authentication with second
factor authentication in google cloud
we start this demo by taking a look at
the familiar active directory
administrative center
we're looking at the contents of the
objects that reside inside
a google cloud managed microsoft active
directory domain
cloud 80 demo one of the users that has
been created
inside this managed active directory
domain is this user with the upn
sid cloud80demo.unix.net
i have pre-configured an ongoing
synchronization from this
managed microsoft ad domain to google
cloud identity
we are now taking a look at the google
cloud identity
admin console and you can see the same
user which we were just looking at in
active directory has been synchronized
up here
additionally i've gone ahead and enabled
two-step verification
for this user with the second factor
authentication being provided by google
cloud
one of the use cases where we can
utilize the second factor authentication
is our os login functionality the
step-by-step guide shows you
how to configure os login with a second
factor authentication
i now switch to the google cloud console
you can see that there is a
vm here named instance one
and as i go into the details for the
specific vm
you will notice that i've gone ahead and
configured
this vm to require os login with a
second factor authentication
now let's take a look at the user's
experience
i'm now going to google cloud console
again but this time
as you can see i'm logged in as the
active directory user
sid when i now try to ssh
into this vm you will notice that i will
get prompted for a second factor
authentication
the type of second factor authentication
that i've configured in this case
is a text message otp so let me go ahead
and type in
the code that i received on my cell
phone
as you can see only upon successfully
validating the second factor
authentication was i able to ssh into
this vm
so as you can see there is quite a bit
that the base
manage active directory service can do
for you we realize adbas security is a
broad and deep topic
and we can further help enhance that
with our industry partners
ativo networks aims to prevent discovery
of your ad infrastructure
they go and distract attackers with
decoy ad credentials so that your real
active directory infrastructure remains
hard to discover
they do not require software to run on
ad domain controllers
or need admin access to active directory
another solution by alcid disrupts the
dynamic of several cyber threats
by exposing misconfigurations and
detecting attacks before widespread
infection
the als solution helps locate and fix
your existing weaknesses
and is continuously uncovering and
fixing new attack pathways
in addition to acid and ativo we have
other industry partners
which are all set to go ahead and meet
your active directory needs across the
board
from citrix itopia semperus and
stellbits
i wanted to thank you for taking the
time today to learn more about our
manage active directory service
and understand how this can go ahead and
help you empower
run your ad dependent workloads more
effectively on google cloud
thank you for joining me and hope you
have a wonderful day